en el vídeo anterior hablamos de cuál es
el color de un punto sobre la superficie
teniendo en cuenta tres factores
1 la cantidad de luz que cae sobre el
punto 2 el modo en que la superficie
refleja la luz y 3 el lugar en que se
encuentra la cámara
para el primer factor el rey fraser
necesita determinar si el punto que está
considerando es visible a la fuente de
luz
en realidad esto es bastante fácil de
responder el rate tracer construye un
rayo que comienza en el punto al que se
le está dando un acabado y se dirige
hacia la fuente de luz estos rayos
dirigidos a la fuente de luz se llaman
naturalmente rayos sombra este es un
ejemplo de un punto que es visible a la
fuente de luz porque el rayo sombra no
le llega a nada más que a la fuente de
luz es importante observar que solo
parte de la luz que cae sobre un punto
viene directamente de las fuentes de luz
a esto se le conoce como iluminación
directa en el mundo real parte de la luz
también viene de otros objetos en la
escena
nota que puedo hacer que rebote la luz
de esta tarjeta y como puedes ver esto
aumenta la cantidad de luz que cae sobre
mi cara este es un ejemplo de
iluminación indirecta
como otro ejemplo de iluminación
indirecta puedes ver un reflejo de la
pelota de tenis en la bola de billar un
rey tracer puede dar cuenta de estos
reflejos enviando otro rayo en dirección
del reflejo la dirección de este rayo
reflejado se determina mediante la forma
en que un rayo de luz rebotaría
naturalmente de la misma forma en que
rebota una bola de billar
esta técnica se usó por ejemplo en cars
2 porque los reflejos sobre los coches
brillantes eran súper importantes para
el aspecto visual de la película
si el objeto es parcialmente
transparente como esta copa de cristal
el rate grazer puede hacer algo similar
y dirigir un rayo en dirección de la
refracción los rayos refractados
atraviesan objetos mientras que los
rayos reflejados rebotan sobre ellos
cuando los rayos atraviesan un objeto
como este cristal los rayos se doblan en
diferentes direcciones en lugar de
continuar en líneas rectas lo que
explica por qué la imagen que ves de mí
a través de este vidrio parece estar
deformada
el rey tracer puede seguir haciendo esto
proyectando rayos enviando rayos
reflejados y refractados para dar cuenta
de los reflejos refracciones etcétera
luego usa todos estos rayos para
determinar el color final del pixel en
el siguiente ejercicio puedes poner a
prueba tu comprensión de estos conceptos